tu m'as pas elle s'éclatait mon rapport
je m'appelle millan mennucci laissé et
je suis la seule tout eu dans ma famille
ne me pas à ma petite ce jeu tout
entendre
[Musique]
beaucoup de guides sur meuf que tu es
logiquement inspire le parle pas mais
vous savez que certaines personnes tous
deux parlent comme moi comme mes amies
comme d'autres personnes il ya des
tweets live attend à l'est quand on
arrive à capter des sons graves at elle
rappelé à l appel
il me dit sur moi aussi les sourires
juste l'instrument de musique des
musiques n'était pas vraiment possible
donc oui il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
soucis jouent d'un instrument de musique
il ya beaucoup de sous écoute de la
musique à rien de crier de tous et
n'entendent pas c'est pas la peine de
cligner des tomates et vous criez vous
différemment et que tout est possible
[Musique]
la vinasse ou de kutti des ratés comme
les grands
on peut pas faire comme tout le monde
org c'est là tous dessinent donne du
capital et rap en commun donc y avait un
peu pâle qui peut noter un petit bossu
par notre chef de l'état d'avoir à peine
de six ans et demi heure d'attenté
audois hâter le pas moi c'est l'autre
ok sauf que fait on à elle bien plus
tard avec cuba les problèmes cachés a
good il sait me parle de fans et
ma mère je suis parti en courant
le coup une information à la série
saints étudie se décaler sur le tard
fermement c'est aimer ça il était une
dupe une grosse partie de retrouver
notre jeu